- I'm starting to get nauseous
and I'm starting to feel lost.
And I forget what time we got here
- Let's just set up camp here.
(lively rag time music playing)
- I know that it is Swedish.
- I imagine it's gotta be pretty big.
- If there's one thing I was raised to do,
it's to hunt a good deal.
So if the deals are
good, I'm gonna love it.
- It's supposed to be a sort of a circus,
and I really enjoy shopping
and circuses, so...
(lively rag time music playing)
- It looks like a 90's roller coaster.
- There's a challenge?
Find the cheapest desk
- The best couch.
- And pasta and everything to make pasta.
- Ooh, look at their
tasteful use of crates.
- This is what happens when Pac-Man dies.
You skin him and you make him into these.
- Help, I'm trapped in an IKEA shower.
- This chair can withstand
even the slowest (beeping).
- So, we've lost Katie
in the depths of IKEA.
- She could be anywhere.
- We're gonna have to
backtrack to find her.
- Bed number one, bed number
two, bed number three.
Let's chase some birds!
- There she is.
- Best one, found the best mattress.
Found it.
- You think, like, we can haggle?
- We haven't seen light in hours.
We don't know how long it's been.
I just wanna, like, spend money now.
(lively rag time music playing)
- When I started I was very
excited, cuz I love shopping.
- We were like little ants,
finding our way through the ant tunnel,
- And then immediately
when we got upstairs,
I found salad spinners.
This is step one on my pasta journey.
Because I always use my
salad spinner as my strainer.
- Things were laid out very cute,
but then you get a couple rooms deep
and you realize that you're
just in this apartment
that goes on forever.
- And then eventually we found the map.
We realized when we got to this map,
this place was (beeping) huge.
- You keep going along a path,
but it's not really
clear where it's going.
And like the deeper you
go, the creepier it got
with, like, people's clothes being there.
I can't take any of it off.
Joke's on you, I'm takin' these.
- There were probably
more comfortable couches
than the one I picked,
but I liked how mine looked.
This is the couch I picked, the URKSA.
Cuz I love the orange color of it
and the name reminds me of
Steve Urkle's girlfriend.
- The next one was the cheapest desk,
which I think I found because
I found a laptop table.
40 dollars, 40 dollars is
the cheapest desk easily.
- We finally reached
the middle of the store,
we were exhausted, we thought
this must be the end of the store.
It was actually only the half way point.
But this was where they
had the famous IKEA food.
Which, to their credit,
that food is really cheap.
- And so then, we had to
make it out through another
half of the store, which then became
tiny little plates, and
candles, and lamps, and stuff.
- Wait, now grab a cart.
- I won't have to sleep
on that couch anymore.
- Why are we grabbing a cart?
- Wait, are we only now at
the part where you buy stuff?
- That was initially confusing,
because I started to look
for pasta stuff right away,
and it was sort of scattered
throughout the different kitchens.
There's no bowls.
Where do we...
What do we have?
- We're gonna have to turn
into a new location for bowls.
- All of a sudden, we go
down to this marketplace,
and now there it all is.
Pasta, (clapping) four bowls,
some forks, strainer, pot.
Nailed it!
The marketplace was a weird purgatory.
- But this is the area
where I started getting
pretty impressed with the prices.
- You got three bucks?
I got a lamp for you.
And so after you make it
through all the store parts,
then you go to the warehouse.
- It was like a Home Depot
but there was nobody there to help you.
- Do we have to build them?
And set up a display for
whole new set of customers?
- Oh wait, wait, wait.
Do we get to use the forklift?
- Do we work here now?
They had these computers
where you look up a numbering system
to find the thing that you're looking for.
EKTORP, EKTORP. I found it.
The numbering system has
nothing to do with the order
that they're actually
placed in along the walls.
So, then I just had to look for the name,
and Katie made fun of me
for even trying to use the number system.
- What can I say?
I went in, looked for my couch, found it.
I won!
- I would say IKEA actually
exceeded my expectations
because I didn't think it would be so big.
- The idea of going back now, is terrible.
I don't wanna go back.
But those prices were so low.
- I bought a memory foam
pillow for 13 bucks.
- I would probably go back.
- It was an emotional roller coaster.
I think people say, like, if you want
a relationship to last,
you should travel together.
But I think what they mean to say is,
if you want a relationship to last
you should travel to IKEA together.
- [Voiceover] Restrooms may
be located near the restroom,
but there's toilets right here.
- So, Danion what are you
doing to the bathroom?
- What does anyone do in the bathroom?
It's private business.